darkness two survivors of a shipwreck
cling to a cliff face
fellow passengers tried desperately to
hold on to the Rocks below these
terrifying scenes unfolding on the shore
of the Greek island of kythira Rescuers
try to bring another man to safety with
a life belt
but in rough season with little purchase
he falls back into the water
incredibly Rescuers managed to save 80
people in the dark in 70 kilometer an
hour winds
the survivors were brought to a nearby
school for welcome shelter and rest
several had traveled from Afghanistan
they said the captain had lost his way
the boat swept onto the rocks
it was a small shift not for all these
people we were about nine to five people
but the ships was just for 20 or 30
persons a month of woman's guide and
then young guys and old men we couldn't
do anything for them we thought just how
they died
hundreds of kilometers to the east on
the Island of Lesbos there were similar
scenes a dinghy carrying around 40
people had capsized in The Heavy Seas
images from the hospital showed some of
those rescued young women from Africa
the Greek government praised emergency
crews for saving so many
people who were thrown by senseless
Smugglers into the Raging Waters of the
Aegean Sea on boats that do not meet any
safety standards such irresponsible
behavior and at the same time the
misdemeanors of turkey from whose Shores
these boat set sail unfortunately lead
to tragedies
of cathira on Thursday Grim evidence of
the overnight tragedy among the wreckage
a number of bodies the Turkish
government has recently accused Greece
of using its ships to turn back migrant
boats endangering lives after a sharp
reduction in recent years of Asylum
Seekers sailing from Tokyo to Greece the
numbers and the risks are beginning to
rise once more Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera